okay everybody it's your boy
psychobabble here with my main man Kanye
West and we're playing the mission the
job which is all about acquiring the
days but the tetteh nadir I can't even
[ __ ] talk I got too much the same in
my mouth you know saying okay let's see
who these Punk's are I know there's
pongs here you might just like falling
just [ __ ] around the whole time oh
[ __ ] it's a marked man hunter that's
better [ __ ] ready steady I be okay
did you know there's actually uh you
know people always talking about the
sympathetic nervous system and passed
with that I can fight or flight response
you know when you see an enemy you
either fight like fight or flight well a
lot of people now there's actually a bad
one it's called I'm son and it's like a
it's a tied slam chef it's like when you
know you can't fight no you can't run
but we can do is suck and you like suck
and suck and suck and basically he just
keep on sucking until pretty much until
your situation changes when you have to
to fight him like stopped sucking and
say like I'm done sucking I'm gonna
fight you or like like run away like
from soccer game when you got a chance
you know like I mean that's basically
how it goes and I I have to say like
it's a pretty good way to like you know
do like it's nice to have a third option
no no it's about
like if you're like a football team and
you won't have a play that no knows
about it's actually nice sneaking done
fighting now Oh what is this look like I
haven't gotten that situation cessation
of hostilities complete oh but I'm just
saying I'm not I'm not above it ready
yeah I guess I was everything i do is
that all yes what the flying [ __ ] oh I
was like what the [ __ ] ok I catch a sec
I like it hey honey like what happened I
can just take all that are there so many
[ __ ] excited being watched no I let
me tell you something I [ __ ] hate hey
this lighting let me say how high I can
it happen like that really um she's I
need so many [ __ ] minds oh I'm like
okay good that is this
why is everything red [ __ ] the game
is that cell [ __ ] up to me like they
need [ __ ] arrows at glare that that
what is that beeping there we go
ok
all right past her what the [ __ ] is
going on here okay hello sorry you need
to carry some things all right okay um i
think i need those really hate the
goodnight level ok get ready steady oh
[ __ ]
how'd you saw a hot fire here but
there's more we're on the next I don't
see any fun
oh is that her over there okay where is
the laser that in there there you go
walk in it a [ __ ] that's crazy okay hell
anyway I got to go back to this thing
alas sir
sniper rifle
you should take that sniper rifle
I never know what i might hit it
okay okay how is that campfire No
I didn't come all this way for that you
know that's what I'm saying shut okay
essex is no favorite scratch Jesus this
one looks pretty tough shut the [ __ ] up
[ __ ] oh my god on fire to his bluster
yes I do
hey okay cessation of hostilities
complete I get some [ __ ] ahead
I need any more science
[ __ ] I got an let's see yeah see here
huh
that's pretty good math right
oh my god there's so many
yeah this is really good
right there
jay says can like we like settle down
with the gun shower like this is how
it's gonna be
hmm ok I just blow my way through the
road is this safe there's a lot of fire
here
what is this
I don't believe it grant actually went
to Colonel autumn it got approval for
her damned efficiency guidelines all
experiments will be carried out I
explained I guess I'm starting to have
serious misgivings about leadership
around here okay I'm not the fact that I
let's go great time to fight back a
little harder that's all right yes
fighting over
oh oh very cute tosser
watched
sorry i was texting on sexy you guys
matters and I [ __ ] tight that's good
yeah I love it ready steady
the second batch s list at all okay okay
save now this is just this is just great
this is everything I wanted I gave me
enough total total confusion that a loss
and I like it satellite no la la I'm
gonna pop out right here hey when I pass
it watching yeah okay
okay oh no we're out of medics okay okay
let's let's take this seriously now okay
we're gonna shut shut it's only snicker
color but then we're taking off the bag
boy okay we're fida oh where are you
okay I don't know it's going on with
that but that's hot
what's that all I know where I lat
there you are you went quiet for time
and that signal came in strong from your
anyways you see behind you